If we do everything right to help heal our cancer, why does it always work?
Well, that's kind of keeping in the same question. We can do everything right for any type of
situation. And what we think is right is, you know, let's say we, okay, we do some toxicity tests.
If I don't have a bunch of toxins, and so we do everything right to help ourselves detox,
and we start eating correctly, and we start taking supplements to detox, and we start doing detox-type
therapies and coffee enemas, and doing sodas, and we do everything right. And we might run that
toxicity test again in six months or a year, and it still shows a lot of toxins. What is going on?
It can be extremely frustrating. We live in a toxic world. We live in a poison world.
There's a good documentary that keeps coming up on my feet that I want to watch. It's something
about forever and forever or something. And it's about the forever chemicals. And all I've seen,
I haven't watched the documentary, but I've just seen a short little clip about it, and it talks about
how 3M, right here in Minnesota, has made these forever chemicals. And now in the clip,
the scientists will say, it is in every human's bloodstream of the planet. That's a scary thing.
We have literally, we as human race have literally poisoned the planet. It's amazing that we're all
still alive. So we could do everything, quote unquote, right, which is again the only things that we
know to do. And it's, we still don't maintain or obtain health. Ultimately, we have to have,
this is where I push everybody back to you, have to have a faith in Jesus Christ that he is
ultimately your savior. And he is ultimately responsible for your healing. And yes, you are
responsible to do everything that you know to be right. But then you have to fall into the hands
of your savior. Trust him for the difference because we can do everything that we know to be right
and still fail in our endeavor to be healthy. We also have to caution ourselves to not have that
become an idol in our life that we have health, but it be our responsibility to stay healthy. And then
leaving the results to God, keep it from being an idol so that we don't get frustrated when we
don't get what we want.